in any case you look at these little
blips right the jet the epstein thing
was one where you thought gosh this
pedophile thing's a little weird then
you look
at that that show that just went on
netflix this movie called cuties
which talked about how an 11 year old
discovers her love of twerking
and decides to to break up with her
family
because her family's too traditional and
she wants to go to work with her other
preteen friends
i think that's weird very sexualized
poster
now in the state of california the left
wants to legalize pederasty
heterostatic sexual relations between
grown men
and young boys they want to legalize it
i know that sounds impossible
but it's real it's called sb 145.
and it just passed by the way just it's
not even like it was some
random pervert who who just proposed it
and it was shot down
the 40-member state senate in california
by vote of 23-10
just passed which was
a bill introduced by california state
senator scott weiner
uh we have to stop electing people named
weiner they they always
they always live up to the silliness of
their name
scott weiner is from san francisco
you'll be surprised
under sb 145 if a
if an adult has gay sex with a minor
14 years or older and that adult is 10
years
is less than 10 years older than the
person
a judge will have the discretion on
whether or not to
place the individual on the sex offender
registry
so to put that in an example you have a
23 year old guy
who has sex with a 14 year old boy
that is not necessarily a sex crime that
person will not necessarily
be put on the sex offender registry
there might be some other smaller
punishments but to actually register as
a sex offender
no longer have to do that
that's weird what why are we why why is
that a
bill that's creepy and perverted and
weird
and and obviously deeply wrong how on
earth did that get through the
california state senate voting for the
party
as jeff flake suggests we do voting for
the party that is now
actively pushing to legalize pederasty
is that conservative
i guess it's conservative in the sense
that it harkens all the way back to
ancient greece
hurricanes back to you know ancient
athens and socrates and things like that
but that
that's a little too conservative for me
okay if we're just looking at time
scales here
i'd rather stick maybe around 1776 is
okay
in the american tradition that's some
radical stuff though
and you're not going to hear about that
in the mainstream media but that is the
extent of it
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts